bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine
basket féminin le chesnay versailles a
réussi l'exploit de remonter en
nationale 2 les yvelinoises se sont
imposés contre escaudain 65 à 56 ce
dimanche à l'occasion des playoffs de
fin de saison les détails dans ce
magazine apnée andy cabreira a battu ce
dimanche le record des six heures à la
piscine municipale de saint cyr l'école
nous le recevons dans quelques instants
sur ce bateau pour qu'il nous donne ses
premières réactions cyclisme sur piste
la coupe de france fenioux était
organisée ce week-end au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
pistard de l'équipe de france françois
pervis grégory baugé ou la plaisir aux
incendies claire se sont affrontés sur
la piste plus d'informations à suivre
et puis nous parlerons également du
combat du boxeur élan courtois à marvin
petit le boxeur l'an courtois la star
locale affrontera dan sexe ce vendredi
27 mai au cirque d'hiver
on commence par du basket féminin le
chesnay-versailles réussi l'exploit de
remonter en nationale 2 un an tout juste
après l'avoir quitté pour valider un
sans tiquer les yvelinoises le se sont
imposés contre escaudain 65 à 56 en
playoffs le montage est signée romain
respini le chesnay-versailles arraché
son ticket pour remonter dès cette année
en nationale 2 ce dimanche les filles de
vinko bardigues sont dominées escaudain
sur leur terrain 65 à 56 lors du dernier
match des playoffs devant plus d'une
centaine de supporters après un 9 à 0
dans les premières secondes du lcv a
fait la course en tête pendant toute la
partie avec un écart de plus 10 à la fin
du troisième quart temps
on mérite de gagner
on mérite
de monter parce que cette année on avait
que deux de fait je pense que ce soir on
s'est toutes mobilisées au match aller
on n'était pas présente on a on a manqué
beaucoup de choses et on ne devait pas
combative
ce soir on voulait vraiment la victoire
et on s'est battus premier de la saison
régulière avec une seule défaite le
chesnay-versailles termine également sur
la première marche du podium des
playoffs les yvelinoises affiche donc un
bilan de seulement 2 défaites en 26
matches disputés cette saison
notre force c'est vraiment l'équipe
parce que on à se trouver sous des
nôtres c'est un peu difficile et et
c'est ce qui fait qu'on gagne ce soir à
l'état d'esprit que l'équipe devra
garder pour espérer se maintenir la
saison prochaine en nationale 2
l'objectif annoncé par le club après le
basket on passe à la plaie avec un
record qui va à n'en pas douter vous
couper le souffle
ce dimanche 22 mai andy cabreira avila
un apnéiste de 45 ans d'origine cubaine
a battu un record d'apnée la piscine de
saint cyr l'école eux il a parcouru 17
km et 350 mètres le sportif a donc
effacé le record de pascal maes et qui
avait effectué 9 3 km le 7 février
dernier pour nous parler de cette
incroyable performance nous recevons sur
ce plateau
andy cabreira et luna pour qui le
déficit a été a été établi alors on dit
comment vous sentez vous après ce record
machin c'était juste avant j'ai ressenti
retraité heureux d aboutir enfants à
cette aventure humaine aventures d'un
métier et à un tueur d'amour entre lula
et moi la senelec qui épandait couvre
natation avec moi et c'est pour cela
qu'on a tout fait pour qu'elle puisse
obtenir les 6000 euros pour l'achat
d'une combinaison
donc je me sens très en forme de
recommencer si faux
le luna que penses tu du coup de dandy
ça va il a il assuré et on dit comment
vous êtes vous senti tout au long de
votre votre record est ce qu'il ya eu
des moments de doute
par exemple nous si oui à quel moment on
fait ça fait deux mois qu'ils
maintiennent pour cela donc j'étais
préparé mentalement ou physiquement
la seule préoccupation c'est l apathie
physiologique
c'est à dire qu'elle si on va à mon
intensité très importante on risque d
avoir des crampes et les cramps a fait
que après on va s'arrêter pour récupérer
donc la bâtiment talent la partie
physique ça allait et l'appétit
physiologique ou si ça allait donc tout
était parfait les publics les amis
l'étudiant ma famille mon fils
normalement mon papa luna tout le monde
est là et donc mon coeur qui battait à
fond pour tous vous n'avez pas douté non
jamais jamais et vous avez battu le
record vous et même doubler le record
c'était attendu
voilà est mon objectif était de faire
680 longueur ça fait 10 km poêle et y
dépasser des 680 14 longueurs donc je
veux atteindre les 700 mais au niveau
physiologique
j'ai dû m'arrêter pour aller aux
toilettes deux fois et donc c'est obligé
mais sinon je suis ensuite le très très
content très heureux
il n'y a rien à regretter au contraire
de remercier tout le monde des morts
s'est tenue dans cette aventure
et quand vous êtes vous entraîné du coup
pendant français dans la semaine
alors je m'entraîne beaucoup à sec je
m'entraîne pendant une heure j'ai dit
arrêtez la respiration une inspiration
ou minutes 30 pendant une heure avec une
seule inspiration
ça va mettre la pâtée d'adaptation à la
ribère camry et deux fois par semaine
dit maintenant dans l'eau avec des
petits pendre essaie de faire minimum
une heure sans m'arrêter et ça fait des
adaptations physiologique
québec après on peut retenir très
longtemps ensuite il faut bien
s'hydrater donc le départ laissant
agissent et m arrêter toutes les 30
minutes et après j'ai choisi mardi sous
les 20 minutes pour pouvoir m'arrêter
maintenant imminente amènera t avec de
l'eau avec du sucre
sinon c'est pas possible de tenir
vous êtes s'entraîner avec là aussi de
temps en temps à la luna fait beaucoup
d'abonnés oui on lance des cailloux au
fond de l'eau et lula et moi au fond de
l'eau on a le goût père j'aime j'aime
traîner mes cuisses en montant avec luna
en toboggan tous les marches de vos
gants et après on glisse et voilà ça
fait un entraînement aussi et on vous a
donné des conseils peut-être d'autres
aptéis où vous en donner des conseils au
fait pas forcément parce qu'il est si on
discipline tout récente il ya que deux
personnes quelqu'un à qui on l'appelait
à londres et est parce qu un massey est
il qu'il a fait vainqueur des 24 heures
donc et pour le reste c'est beaucoup de
découvertes
donc moi même j'essaie de m'ouvrir des
portes et voir et tester que ça allait
bien pour moi et donc je dirais c'est un
paramètre comme la poste ou les 20
minutes
là les cyclos ventilatoire pour pouvoir
repartir
donc par tous les 30 secondes avec 20
secondes et nash maximum et 10 secondes
de récupération maximum je peux aller
plus vite que ça mais c'est pas c'est
pas les fils et filles qui sait tous la
partie les craintes que je m'arrête et
avant de commencer ce record vous saviez
déjà que vous alliez le battre oui je le
fais en fait vous étiez sûr et certain
âge étant la première fois que je sais
je sais pendant une heure et demie à la
monopalme mais je sentais que j'étais
lettre très facile il ya près de lui que
pascal il a mis les conditions de son
accord il a un ennemi avec biesheim
donc je suis aussi le maître d'oeuvre
tim bevan sont des femmes de natation et
avec cela je fais une heure et demie
après j a réussi à atteindre le record
d'abonnés des pascal en 3h13 avec les
gitans la montée du temps tout de suite
directement à la mairie
je parlais avec les responsables du
sport de la mairie de saint cyr l'école
avec les maires avec l'adjoint du maire
et le dire aujourd'hui
les records battus donc je peux assurer
et une gestion du pouvoir et donc après
jeff koons soit quatre heures après une
fois ci sur un beau coup de g j'ai fait
six ans 19 longueurs après contre x 4
heures et après me suis arrêté et
finalement il tout était parfait et
danser recorman parce que massé vous à
féliciter
en fait dans le monde de la mener même
si on est au courant on est bons amis on
sait dans le conseil on se soutient
et donc on se transmettent toutes les
informations pour participer à la
réussite de notre parce qu'en fait il
l'a fait aussi pour une bonne cause la
cause de la maladie de charcot donc
indien félicité pascal a aussi à
d'autres amnesty qui font des choses
bien évidemment de l'apnée c'est pas la
concurrence à la menace d'un contre une
autre mais surtout d amnistie pour
obtenir de belles choses tous ensemble
dallas menait seul on va vite ensemble
ou moins loin voilà le message qu'il
veut transmettre
j'aimerais remercie à la piscine
essentiel est qu envers marine au
directeur de la piscine à mon copain
chef de bassin loïc aquamondo à tous mes
collègues à bernadette alain soutenu et
c'est encore également pour la bonne
cause on le disait depuis tout à l'heure
voilà c'est encore pour la bonne cause
vous avez un côté combien du coup sûr
sur cette journée on l'a raconté au
total 1898 ou gros c est grâce au dos au
dos du rhin remercier tous les bénévoles
ont donné on a si on a fait des baptêmes
d'abonnés à 5 euros on l'a raconté ça
vaut donc un fervent matin et il y
aurait menti à les amis du codep 68 des
analystes notamment observé depuis
champion du monde d'apnée à arthur hogan
en bout et richard benamou d'amener à
farida des mots venus soutenu et voilà
magnifique avec tout cet argent là est
donc cet argent voilà où va aller cet
argent c'est aja et récolté pour un
geste en plus c'est l'association que la
maman le nacré pour l'humain est donc
une cagnotte sur internet et sur le côté
plus de 3000 euros au total pour cette
robe est nouveau et donc avec la récolte
je connais trop d'eau 1367 haut et avec
les mille huit cent quatre vingt dix
huit euros qu'elle a regretté hier on a
un presqu'à la tendre et 6000 euros pour
luna il aura une autre vous faites pour
le mois juin et on espère avoir les 6000
euros poulain pour qu'ils puissent
tenter de marcher on a tu es fier de
lundi
il a fait une belle performance et est
ce que ce record peut peut être battu
bien sûr ce n'est pas encore enfin
égalable il ya six mois mois pour voir
faut faire vanger vite comme un effet y
est on est mouvant longueur c'était
vraiment un challenge
aujourd'hui il a fait hier un
rayonnement des départs toutes les 30
secondes du départ je fais presque c'est
sa longueur je pense qu'il ya des
samedis liste comporte qui qui peut
s'entraîner avec un traitement
spécifique et peuvent être d'accord
les records les plus importantes c'est
pas leur coque on peut battre et le
nombre de longueurs c'est le recteur
qu'on peut le faire tous ensemble les
rigueurs du coeur les accords d de
l'amitié les vainqueurs des de la nature
humaine pour une cause juste
les records sont faits pour être battus
voilà il pense que oui novotech est
capable de le faire
la question est ce que vous allez et
tenter de battre votre propre record
maintenant bien sûr je pense que je
m'arrêterai pas là avec pascal ans et on
attend en profite et faire 12 heures
d'abonnés et pourquoi pas tenter les 24
heures si tout joue toujours pour la
bonne cause on trouve toujours des cours
sur 12 des causes justes et nobles pour
laquelle on peut se douter et fait des
choses belles la baie comeau transports
sont des sports de partage et voilà qu
est-ce que penser de tout ça merci à
tous les deux d'être passé sur ce
plateau on manquera ne manquera pas de
suivre vos prochaines performances on
dit à l'avenir vos prochains record on
passe maintenant un sport d'endurance
également le cyclisme sur piste
la première manche de la coupe de france
fenioux était organisée ce week-end au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les pistards
de l'équipe de france ce françois pervis
ce grégory baugé ou la plaisir oise 110
claire se sont affrontés sur la piste le
champion olympique jason kenny le
britannique a également participé à la
compétition
les images sont signés à mélanie poker
c'était une grande première au vélodrome
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la première
manche coupe de france fait mieux
organisée par la fédération française de
cyclisme était programmé ce week-end
dans l'enceinte yvelinoise au total une
centaine de pistard élite juniors et
cadets à participer à l'événement le but
c'est de créer un circuit pour nos
meilleurs pistards d'ancône aux pistards
élite
ce sont des époques qui sont inscrites
au calendrier international
ça permet à tous les pistards donc de
marquer des points dans le ranking
international et de créer aussi un film
sur toute la saison est donc levé
d'animer des territoires et donc les
vélos bros parmi les têtes d'affiché on
retrouve et les pistards de l'équipe de
france kevin sireau et michael d'almeida
et françois pervis le britannique jason
kenny triple champion olympique a
également fait le déplacement pour les
cyclistes ce rendez-vous est avant tout
une étape dans leur préparation avant
les jeux olympiques de cet été première
compétition depuis les championnats du
monde à londres au mois de mars
donc ça permet de
faire un point de passage ce évalué par
rapport au premier cycle d'entraînement
qui va se terminer
testé également des vélos des braquets
donc voilà c'est une étape une étape
vers rio dans la construction des cycles
d'entraînement c'est de la préparation
les rendez vous importants on peut pas
se permettre d'arriver toute la saison
sur des rendez vous importants
on a deux trois rendez-vous important
dans la saison et là c'était de la
préparation tout simplement parce qu on
est venu à paris parce que c'est une
compétition européenne face à l'une des
meilleures équipes du monde c'est juste
un rendez vous à mi chemin entre les
championnats du monde et les jeux
olympiques
on essaye de voir la prochaine étape de
la coupe de france fait nous est
programmé les 8 et 9 juillet hier la
dernière manche sans organiser courant
septembre à bourges
au niveau des résultats le trappistes
barre jean mathon a remporté la coupe de
france de l'américaine en vitesse
individuelle le britannique jason kenny
a terminé troisième de l'épreuve chez
les dames sandie clair a pris la
deuxième place du tournoi de keirin
après le cyclisme coup de projecteur sur
le boxeur baring petit
le boxeur de la team farrugia marine
petit sera souvent dit sur le ring au
cirque d'hiver de paris à l'occasion de
la soirée baptisée les princes du ring
le sportif elancourt turf entre à cette
occasion adam sec
originaire de corbeil essonnes pour nous
parler de ce rendez-vous de ce combat
nous recevons sur ce plateau à marvin
petit son entraîneur tanguy farruggia
bonsoir alors on va commencer par votre
préparation marine est ce que vous êtes
prêt est ce que vous êtes à 100%
à quelques jours de l'événement j'ai pas
le choix d'être prêt si posh est prêt
j'ai fait une bonne préparation je me
sens bien dans ma tête et en attend les
résultats sur le ring mandoline et
comment vous sentez vous justement non
encore dans mon corps je suis très bien
là je me sens très bien je me sens fort
fort dans ma tête la théorie il est
comment marine à quelques jours de
l'épreuve
il est bien il est bien danser une
remise en forme c'est un combat de
préparation donc je pense que je pense
qu'il sera encore mieux dans les futurs
combats mais là il est bien on a
peut-être je sais pas le meilleur marvin
petit qu'il n'y ait jamais eu en ce
moment au niveau de sa forme physique où
il a encore des étapes à franchir
non il ya encore des étapes à franchir
avant toute façon il n'est pas champion
du monde
tant que j'ai pas champions du monde ou
encore du travail marvin ce n'est pas le
meilleur marine petit il ya en ce moment
on verra soling mandoline et vous êtes
parti également plusieurs semaines en
thaïlande
est ce que par exemple vous avez appris
les techniques de combat là bas non
jumeaux je me suis entraîné un peu
là-bas j'ai fait en fait j'ai gardé la
forme est en préparation physique et
donc selecting particulière peut-être
vacances c'est puis des vacances en fait
d'accord pas des techniques
particulières
nous allons avoir appris là bas c'est la
boxe thaï c'est plus à vauxaillon je
disais tout à l'heure vous allez
affronter un estonien dame seck
il affiche un bilan de 10 victoires 12
défaites 2 nuls
est ce que c'est un adversaire coriace
ou si l'éternel adversaire facile
comment l'analysez vous mais il n'y a
pas de combat facile
c'est dans la boxe
faut pas rêver à tout moment c'est un
boxeur il a rencontré des grands
champions donc je pense le battre
vendredi
c'est un adversaire pour vous connaissez
bien je ne connais pas bien alors j'ai
en fait j'ai jamais vu je devais sur les
vidéos comme comme vous voyez là mais
moi je n'ai jamais vu autant dit donc
qu'ils avaient pu être un petit peu
analysé ce combat où vous la lisez
comment cet adversaire
ben c'est quelqu'un qui a rien à perdre
qui va tenter sa chance pour monter dans
les échelons puisque l'âge et puis son
palmarès parle il a je crois qu'il a
jamais été battu avant la limite
donc c'est quelqu'un qu'il faut pas
sous-estimer
il peut mettre un mauvais coup et marine
j'espère porte on est dans là on est on
est dans un sport où tous abrège d'une
seconde un autre donc j'espère pas que
ce n'est pas lui qui mettra voilà je
disais 10 victoires 2 nuls 12 défaites
finalement c'est peut-être plus un
combat de préparation comme épicier sa
commande à l'opération mais bon il faut
savoir qu'il a toujours perdu chez les
adversaires
des décisions ou sont des fois serrée
c'est bien qu'il faut pas sous-estimer
seule vraie défaite qu'il a eu c'est son
champion de france maintenant ces voix
là c'est les gars moi personnellement
c'est quelqu'un qui a rien à perdre ils
veulent rencontrer mardi pour prendre sa
chance
donc c'est pas quelqu'un
qu'il faut sous-estimer marvin c'est un
vice versa l'île touristique de samui et
vous allez mettre en place quelle
stratégie du coup dans ce combat vous
allez être offensif dès le début vous
mais j'allais vous allez justement
essayer de gérer pour l'emmener un peu
plus loin dans les rangers parce que je
suis prêt physiquement je vais commencer
du début jusqu'à la fin
à fond donc pas tentant maura temps mort
ra pas de temps mort c'est la bonne
stratégie qu'il faut adopter vraiment y
aller à fond des premiers à rendre
il ya eu six rondes et bonbons avec au
but si on peut abréger le combat on a
mal géré le combat maintenant c'est le
but voilà maintenant on attend de voir
un grand marvin petit pour passer à
l'étape supérieure
quand on voit les combats de dnssec on
remarque que sa garde est très basse est
ce que c'est un avantage justement pour
marvin j'espère bien j'espère bien donc
marvin va y aller de façon offensive il
va ne va pas défendre du tout du coup
pendant pendant son combat
attention encore dit avant pas défendre
du tout on n'est pas dans un match de
foot ou agen il faut toujours lever les
mains surtout surtout tarifs voilà mais
bon le but est de jeu marvin petit marc
sa place pour
l'échelon au dessus c'est ce à quoi
justement l'échelon supérieur on espère
le championnat d'europe à doha pour
novembre
sentez vous vous sentez prêt un mari ou
un peu lâché entre et moi même même si
tu étais on va s'entraîner dur là je
veux pas lâcher c'est tout l'été je vais
vous montrer et donc le championnat
d'europe puis le championnat du monde
c'est ça votre prochaine échéance est
exactement c'est aller au but de uchiwa
jetons pas de rock chevalier championnat
du monde j'espère a ajouté le champion
du monde champion de france
enfin ça ne vous concerne plus âgés la
chine titre je veux plus entendre parler
plus du tout maintenant ça sera repères
au niveau mondial européen et mondial
je suis pressé dans les deuxièmes eu
donc maintenant je pense aller je pense
que j'ai ma chance pour aller aux jo pas
d'or tandis vous êtes d'accord avec
marvin da sa chance on a déjà on est
comme deux là on va on n'a rien à perdre
on est dans gm europe et puis c'est
c'est quand même grandiose de rôle de
faire un championnat d'europe
voilà c'est pas la chapelle france je
pense qu'il a fait le tour
il a renvoyé la salle des fêtes il avait
envie de celle de mendy mendy qui a
réussi à se classer dans les deux
premiers mondiaux en 2012 je prends des
mitres elle égalé le combat de son
combat mais là il la série las il s'est
classé mondial le deuxième mondial il ya
une semaine quinze jours là à peu près
donc
c'est quelqu'un voilà marvin il a le
niveau de mendy voire au dessus mais
il faut battre sur le progrès c'est tout
et marine doit se recentrer sur lui ou
sur ses adversaires sur les deux en boxe
il faut rien laisser passer
voilà sans les 2 marvin si c'est
quelqu'un qui a besoin de besoin d'être
entouré et qui une fois qui l'entouré
ben rien qu'ils arrêtent on comptait
également sur vos supporters je pense ce
vendredi au cirque d'hiver et avaient ri
beaucoup de supporters de mémoire donc
on va faire des spectacles comme
d'habitude vous êtes un showman shadow
rochman je suis un vrai showman et vous
avez pas eu de choses et vous allez
jouer justement sur l'appui du public
pourra s est renversé adversaire faire
un très très beau pc spectacle je vais
avoir un chanteur américain qui vient
des états unis qui récents dont je me
suis plus trop c'est quoi sinon je vais
juré tout à l'heure mais c'est un
chanteur qui a percé aux états unis et
qui commence à percer votre enfance
tanguy quand on connaît la fougue de
marvin petit comment on commet fait pour
le canaliser connaissant son entraîneur
oula l'aiment chaud il aime faire le
spectacle le show ça me dérange pas tant
que ça se passe sur le ring voilà ce qui
se passe à côté ça me dérange mais c'est
quelqu'un qui malgré qu'ils soient
showman c'est quelqu'un qui est assez
humbles donc
faut pas les voilà c'est quelqu'un qui a
un grand coeur ça voilà c'est ce qui
fait ses qualités ses défauts
après on aime ou on n'aime pas le
showman toujours utile qui fait le plein
quand il boxe et c'est ce qui plaît aux
promoteurs votre pronostic pour ronnie
j'espère qu'il va gagner dans les quatre
premiers rangs à la pesée nageuse et
j'espère ça s'arrache au jazz et je
voulais c'est quand même qu'on va se
dérouler quand même mardi mais vous
servez chaud de la musique comme une
grande on revit pronostics
personnellement je pense si je touche
bien je pense arrêtent ou 2e 2e ou 3e ci
joue bien et 2ème 3ème et l'arrêtent
vous avez un dernier message vous avez
10 secondes pour lui adresser un message
aux autres adversaires
j'espère qu'ils aient peur parce que je
tire très mal et chose tiens toi prêt le
message est passé merci à tous de passer
sur se bat on vous souhaite de réaliser
un gros combat marine petit ce vendredi
et une voix de victoires merci à vous
d'être passé sur ce plateau on passe
maintenant au reste de l'actualité
yvelinoise cette rubrique part du hockey
sur gazon le racing club de france situé
à versailles organisé ce week-end le
dernier tour des play-offs du top-4 golf
de la boulie dans la cité royale la
compétition réunissait les quatre
meilleures équipes de france versailles
lyon saint germain en laye et donc le
club local versailles on écoute le coach
de l'équipe versaillais sgae le foulard
il analyse les performances de son
équipe et les quatre micros de cette
fois âne à manille c'est une équipe i
forget qui serre générées depuis depuis
quelques temps on a la chance d'avoir
quelques arrivées à noël et c'est
surtout une équipe qui est en plein boom
et avec beaucoup d'envié beaucoup
d'envié pour la suite et sur l'obtention
du titre et c'est une équipe qui a au
début de son cycle à mon avis donc
donc voilà oui j'envisage plein de
bonnes choses pour cette équipe
versailles a remporté ses deux matches
du week-end les joueurs de la cité
royale ont battu à lille 4 à 0 et saint
germes ans les 3 à 2 l'équipe termine
première du top 4 la finale se jouera le
29 mai prochain à douille on continue
sur par une association caritative
cinquante sportifs de haut niveau
étaient dans les yvelines ce mardi les
athlètes ont participé à la 24e édition
du tibre est qu'au golf de la
queue-lez-yvelines
comme tous les ans les joueurs se sont
affrontés dans une partie de golf avant
de passer quelques minutes avec des
enfants venus de trappes et de
versailles dans la soirée une vente aux
enchères était organisée au profit des
sceaux s gaz l on écoute les réactions
au micro de mélo niveau qui est champion
apporter vraiment des choses collector
et l'ensemble de l'argent va permettre
de financer 200 trains en île de france
et au sénégal
laurent blanc nous a porté le maillot
devait rater le maillot de l'équipe du
psg signé de tuzla thann et c'est le
ballon nous avons la raquette de yannick
noah la raquette les règles quatre
raquettes des quatre finalistes de coupe
davis
nous avons la baisse de philippe
candeloro nous avons pas d des traits
des choses très prestigieux c'est
important pour nous parce que nous avons
forcément on prendre du plaisir à jouer
au golf mais en même temps ça ramène des
fonds pour une association et qui va
aider les enfants donc forcément
alors quand les deux sont cumulés on est
au sort le ballon signé par tous les
joueurs du paris saint germain a été
vendu 2500 euros au total à
l'association a récolté plus de 16 mille
cinq cents euros
le reste des enchères sera mise en vente
à l'occasion de l'open de france de golf
qui se tiendra à saint quentin en
yvelines en termine ce magazine à part
du football ont joué ce week-end la 25e
journée du championnat de division
honneur versailles est toujours en
course pour terminer le championnat en
tête du classement les versaillais
deuxième avant la rencontre ont battu ce
dimanche les murs au troisième du
classement de butin au classement les
joueurs de youssef schibbye sont à trois
points du premier créteil lusitanos avec
un bilan de 16 victoires et seulement 2
défaites depuis le début de la saison on
termine par du baseball les cougars de
mon team moto ne se sont facilement
imposés contre st juste rambert ce week
end lésigny montants n'ont pas fait de
détails en remportant la partie sur le
score de 12 à 1 à l'extérieur la
deuxième partie a été annulée à cause de
la pluie
au classement les cougars sont toujours
deuxième avec seulement deux défaites en
neuf matches disputés
c'est la fin de 7,8 sport merci d'avoir
suivi je vous retrouve jeudi prochain
pour le tall que si on parlait sport
très belle soirée sur tv fil 78